[Laughter]
I'm forced to think of some black holes
somewhere in the presentation let's see
if it comes up or not
um
okay so hi everyone uh great to be here
and thank you to the organizers for
organizing this wonderful event and uh
and inviting me
[Applause]
thank you
so uh
this title is about this uh sorry this
uh work it's a joint work with Prashant
or something maybe somewhere around here
hiding
okay uh anyway so don't work with
Prashant and it's about Collision
resistance so money yesterday talked
about Collision resistance also uh no I
don't think it talked about distribution
progressions it's not about a
multi-collision resistance but anyway
I'll uh I'll reintroduce these Notions
and show you uh what I think is a
surprising connection between these uh
two Notions okay so let's start with the
basics so uh I assume that a lot of you
are familiar with Collision resistant
hashing it's one of the most basic uh
Primitives
um in cryptography so these are
basically hash functions that are
shrinking so you know by being by virtue
of being shrinking there are a lot of
conditions but nevertheless it's
computationally hard to find these
collisions and these are extremely uh
Central throughout both practice and
theory of cryptography so this is a
quote from the Shah three standards so
really when people think of a
cryptographic hash function this is one
of the most basic features that they're
looking for
right and you know in theory you have a
lot of applications for uh for such uh
Collision resistant hashing in
particular you know one of my favorites
is the succinct arguments constant round
statistically hiding commitments
um you know barack's result and black
box says zero knowledge and so on
okay
so let's formalize things a little bit
so in you know throughout theoretical
computer science when talking about
Collision resistant hashing we typically
think of a hash function family right so
let's think for some piston we'll talk
about it in a bit uh about hash
functions mapping n Bits to n minus one
bit so as promised they're shrinking we
want them to be efficiently computable
right so denoting the family by Capital
H and each function inside the family by
little age you want you know given
little H and then input X you want to be
able to compute active X efficiently but
it should be hard for uh computationally
bounded adversary to find collisions
so far okay
okay so you know following the theme of
this Workshop you're looking for a
minimal assumption in cryptography and
the question is you know can you make do
with a weaker notion than Collision
resistance suppose you have a situation
in which you have this sort of shrinking
hash function in which sadly enough you
know there's a way to find pairwise
collisions but you know it's hard to
find three-way conditions okay so this
is called an object called
multi-collision resistant hash functions
and uh you know the definition here is
similar we're going to talk about it a
little bit where the definition title go
but these are basically you know as
before we have a family of hash
functions efficiently computable but now
oops it should be hard for an adversary
given the description of the hash
function to find you know this set x
capital x of of size T these are two
distinct elements that all hash to the
same value hard to find the t-way
Collision okay so natural generalization
notice for this notion to be you know
none non-trivial I need the shrinking to
be at least I'd like the factor
otherwise such big collisions may not
exist yes
and there are as dark extensions uh form
you know you have to compute exactly but
yes
okay
so I want to talk a little bit about
this factor of like how much you shrink
by
so typically when talking about regular
Collision resistant hash functions
basically we don't care once you have a
shrinkage of sort of one bit but then
you know you can get whatever you want
uh morally true but imprecise proof is
you know do this just compose a function
with yourself
okay
um
so basically you know as a notion we can
think of one bit of shrinkage you can
get whatever you want
um what about mcrh
I don't know fourth once why not try it
again
so the problem is when you do this you
know even if you have just like it's
possible to find pairwise collisions as
you keep doing this the number of
collisions you can find grows
exponential
so it's much more complicated
turns out you can do something uh
somewhat better so near an Omer showed a
method for doing this better but instead
it grows quite dramatic number of
collisions so here we really so my point
is that oh this a lot has to do with you
know the wonderful fact that one to the
K is equal to one but two to the K is
not equal to one
um
yeah depends okay
okay so basically when we talk about
this notion I like to keep track of also
the shrinkage by how much is my hash
protection shrinking so we're going to
be talking about a t l and crh meaning
that it's hard to find collisions of
size T and you're losing at least
elements
okay
good okay Insanity check you know if you
plug in t equals uh two and that equals
one we got the standard function
okay so a couple of words about prior
works on this notion so the first work
that I'm aware of that studied this
notion is a work of Jewel was kind of
more practice oriented talk you look
looking at specific hash function uh
construction iterated hash functions and
studied multi collisions uh there the
first Theory work that I know of that
studied multi collisions is by yeah
studies in a practical setting could be
trying to see normal position no so he
was he wanted to show that basically
multi-collision implies division
resistance for these functions or from
his perspective if we can find some
collisions you can find about equations
so this work of money you know it was
sort of focused on studying the
computational relative problem but
introduced the connection to this notion
of mcrh
and then you know somewhat ironically we
had the three-way Collision of paper
studying uh Collision resistance
three-way Collision resistance function
so work uh with Prashant uh akshayanitai
and work this work that I mentioned
before the alarm and another work of
Elon and money and Elon I'll give sort
of a more systematic study of mcrachel
mentioned some of the results and we
collided MIT when yes we I came to to
talk about it with you and somebody we
hear the same stuff
we started talking about and then we see
on the side
exactly about
thank you science science yeah
um okay and the last paper that I want
to mention which is really an
inspiration for this work is another
word by uh which shows that if you have
an mcrh then you can construct a
distribution of crh so a hash function
in which it's hard to find random
pairwise collisions but nevertheless it
may still be possible to find worst case
collisions okay
okay so you know this uh as the title
sort of uh was meant to indicate this
paper was about studying the relation
between crh and mcrh and up here it's
not clear what we should think so you
know having started work with this
notion it really has a feeling that mcrh
are qualitatively a different Beast than
crh and I think this domain extension
thing with it with a with the shrinkage
really sort of hints to that so that's
sort of my first uh not just first
reaction to this notion of mcrh on the
other hand if you look at things that
you can actually construct from mcrh
well you know
it requires you know writing papers
which is a good thing but you can do
most of the things right so in
particular content round statistically
hiding commitment you can do still from
mcrh succinct arguments uh beautiful
works that showed how to do succinct
arguments you know in the flavor of
Killian's work so you can do these
things and though this begs the question
uh standard Collision resistant hash
function is actually stronger than mcrh
okay
so our main results are that in some
settings you know I'll explain the
results but in in some sense the answer
is no
um but in a very particular sense so
I'll show you what the main results are
so the first main result is that if you
give me an mcrh in which it's hard to
find three-way collisions could be
possible to find pure escalation to try
to find three way collisions and it
needs to be shrinking by a factor of
half a bit more than half so not not too
bad kind of standard if that's true then
I can construct for you a collision
resistant hash function
okay you can go from three-way mcrh to
to standard crh there's a star that I'll
explain a little bit later okay so not
exact but
okay
good but this is only for three
so what about four uh so you can do it
also for four so if you give me uh MCI
rating which it's hard to find
conditions of size four uh we still know
how to do it we need better shrinkage it
needs to shrink to a factor of like one
over six
we can still do it
okay you know you only have the bounded
space in the slide
um so what about five
well that's open if you give me a five
mcrh which shrinks to anything log
squared I don't know how to do anything
with it
well actually I don't know something I
don't have to be the four-way mcr8 out
of it
looks silly because I have a theorem but
the shrinkage is not good enough so I
can't apply it
okay so these Transformations come at a
cost so even no matter even log get to
the uh
okay what I can do in general is if you
give any T and MCH it can reduce T to
some for some values of T Prime but the
shrinkage there's a cost of the
shrinkage
and it's a terrible formula I won't show
you what it is but just to give the
flavor if you give me you know an mcrh
of it hard to find the size 100
collisions which shrinks uh to like one
over ten then I can build from it one
which is hard to find collisions of size
50 which has a you know shrinks to uh
forty percent
questions
also 5152 sure okay 45 something and it
depends it's a terrible formula and uh
and I need to plug it in and see yes
which can help us
we have a candidate idea I'm not sure
no I don't know this is really about
studying you know MCH versus crh
um he was saying something to him about
the formula is complicated but in
general it works for any TNT practice
people from 100 to no no for example I
don't have to go from five to uh four
four
like the formula applies for every tnl
but maybe at some point it becomes if
you go from five to two then it just
won't be shrinking yeah got it we're 20
minutes and my other question for five
do you have any like Intuition or
barriers
will not worse
um it is but it is pretty specific topic
yeah so there's no barrier like black
box barrier that you can go from here no
no but that is open
be aware of Black Box barriers
it doesn't show you just in the sense
that the output is is not short I mean
is it does it still have collisions or
do you just get a function I get
something that is not shrinking within
the check how the provisions behave it's
interesting try to try to then a hash or
something I would assume that you know
the articles I don't know
is the barrier to getting to two
searches the same or different than the
barriers that you get to the place to to
a place where you can start the
extending the domain or whatever
extending the street like even though
extending the domain even for three is
really hard you lose a lot you can go to
two and then you can extend there that
that I can do uh but that sort of I can
only do the domain extension really fast
too
the barrier for doing extension is
nothing better so what you could hope to
do so this sort of transformation is
something that reduces T but increases
at you might want to try to alternate
right uh we tried
so uh do we have a guess towards like a
question like you're dealing the answer
is like yes or no and this answer is
interesting
um
I will say okay the other question is
she doesn't use need crh
o
at least for the Twitter apps of crh I'm
serious suffice
so like for example previous protocol
there is a much more complicated analog
that works with mcrh so is there any app
that you don't know
um you know the concrete apps you know
file storage you post your file on the
cloud you want to make sure you download
you got the same thing
if it's a series and you're very happy
okay
but you know they can probably solve it
with more traits but
okay so I want to show you that the
first idea of the result and I would
also explain the start
of how we do it okay so actually let's
talk about what we don't what we don't
do is not use a standard cryptographic
reduction so what is the standard
cryptographic reduction how does usually
cryptography work well if we're trying
to build the Primitive B from primitive
a in our case a crh from mcrh what do
you do well
you take your primitive uh a you use it
you throw in some algebra or
communitorics or some clever tricks
typically the way that your construction
of B uses A's as a black box
right just query
then okay you're happy you have the
construction but you also want the
security proof the way that that works
is that you take you consider some
adversary for your cons for this
Construction
and you show that you can use such an
adversary to get sort of this green
adversary for the original construction
a and typically also the the way that
the green monster uses the Red Devil is
as a black box
and they also use the original primitive
as a black box and this you know most
construction cryptography follow this
right it's called the fully Black Box
reduction
so our construction is not going to be
of this relation
so at the high level and this is really
following aidon and Eden's paper here's
our approach
so we start off with an mcrh trying to
eventually get the crh
what we're going to do is to build a
candidate crh it's a candidate
two options either it's good or it's not
good
oh and this candidate is used mcrh the
black box it's circular either it's good
or it's not good if it's good you know
I'd have to end the talk early so let's
assume that it's not good
uh but if it's good then we're done if
it's not good then there is an adversary
whether someone who breaks this
candidate crh
so what I'm going to do is to use this
adversary in order to construct
a different crh
okay so given this adversary I'll
construct a different crh this year it
will use the adversary as a black box
and the original mcrh and the fact that
it's an adversary for this candidate CH
will make the CR execute
for example
[Music]
if you think about it
I'm not sure exactly what you mean
so it's nice I think it's an interesting
but it has some you know repercussions
if I have yet I think of it just as like
more interesting stuff
um so first of all you know this is not
constructive if you come along and give
me you know your favorite best mcrh that
you love and you ask me you know wrong
you promised me a series I know I can
promise you that it exists I cannot show
it to you why because you know I have a
candidate theoretic I can show that one
to you but I don't know if it works or
not and if it doesn't I need the
adversary I don't know what the address
right so I'll talk maybe about Universal
I think constructions in a second
um I'll talk at the end of it though but
you know Universal instructions
yeah so this is an example Central proof
the second thing has to do with
religious question so we usually in
crypto we model adversaries as
non-uniform adversaries if we do this
then you know we inherit an uniformity
in our construction so evaluating the
crh will be done by a non-uniform
algorithm
if we think of adversaries uniformed in
the construction of the uniform so what
it's just one shot the the thing it's
like either the first construction is
good or the second one is good you don't
need to like recurse and say oh this one
is not good adversary
and that's a big family because the
second one might has a call to an
adversary if I wanted to enumerate like
here's all the lists one of them works
that's a big clue different adversaries
there's no way priority polynomial bound
yeah yeah
okay the last thing is you know if we're
talking about standard cryptography you
know
um we have we want a big security
everywhere but that doesn't mean that
the potential adversary only works
infinitely often but that means that our
construction also only works Infinity
often but it doesn't it your original
thing is good so if you have a combiner
between these two things then yeah I
don't know
because for every impact you've done
it's like uh yeah it's more complicated
okay
um more questions
okay so traffic back to your question
the star is about being infinitely often
and then uniform and you know
non-constructed with that
okay so I want to show you uh you know
it was the bird's eye view let's see how
it's done
um the next one is going to be an
elephant yeah
okay so let's focus on the basic theorem
how we go for for starters from a 3M crh
to a 2m series regular series
so we'll start off with our you know
hash function family H let's assume that
it's a 3mcrh with this add bits of
shrinkage that disappear
and just uh just to emphasize I'm going
to maybe uh was asking age itself might
be an awful awful Series right it would
have collisions back into it you can
even come equipped with a button that
gives you random collisions to be
terrible to try to do some sort of
hashing tricks that doesn't seem to work
um but we will try in a sense so what
we're going to do is introduce another
uh
function family G it's going to be
non-cryptographic we'll see later what
properties we need this is a mapping
again the same end bits as H to M bits
and I'm simply going to do concatenation
so given this family G which I have not
specified yet we'll see what it doesn't
need to do later
now to Hash an input X I just put output
h of X but I append also G of X and I
think of both H and G as the key to this
fam this function family f
which are so good
this this that does have a flavor of a
standard Construction
okay so you know the big question is is
this construction secure or not well and
it's small
yes and I want it to be shrinking so we
need to we'll do that comfortably later
on okay
this needs to be shrinked but the
question is you know is it a crh and I
don't know as before if yes we go home
early uh so that's assume it's not
um it means that there's an adversary
there's an adversary that breaks this
candidate crh so what is this adversary
doing
right it gets a description of the hash
King so H and G and it types two
different inputs X1 and X2 that form a
condition both on H energy given the you
know that F computes both of them
okay nice
and you know let's assume for starters
that a is perfect it works on every
input line for probability one okay
um good so I want to try to use a to
find larger collisions of H and then to
violate its multiplication resistance
so let's see let's suppose that I run so
I'm trying to now violate the Collision
resistance of H so let's suppose that I
uh run a on input H and sum Gene that I
can come up with then you know I get a
collision
then I run again with the same H and
some different Gene from G Prime and
I'll get some other position
and now I want to ask myself
can we find a gng prime so that these
values collide
if so I'm very very happy because I you
know apparently have like a forward
position
something like that
if not that so it means like if I can it
means that I broke H which is a
contradiction
which seems to indicate that they should
be hard to find GMG Prime that collide
right so a collision in the adverse in
some sense so I'm going to use a so that
a is Collision resistant
it's hard to find collisions for this
adversary
in the sense we will be specific more
much more confused why is it a four-way
Collision because the first pair under
age forget G is not the same as the
second pair right but so so if I manage
to find GNC Prime so that these guys are
the same oh even under age yes or the
same underage that's what I care about
when I say you hear Collide I mean that
the H of X1 is equal to H of X1 Prime if
I meant to find G and G Prime like that
then I'm very happy maybe
yes
again can you repeat what is the role of
G here what is g so Json you think of it
as an additional input that the
adversary gets what is this information
or something some additional information
about uh about
um X and and it's assumed that you know
you can find collisions here now I'm
trying to run it
um differently with different with
different G's and get different you know
I should get different collisions if I
get the same one then I'm very happy but
it should which means that it should be
difficult to find this
the music or randomized sorry
do I assume it to be you know the best
thing with the deterministic pronoun
it's perfect for example to one so I'll
just fix the princes
um a question
can you repeat this thing about the
change right so yeah so let's see let's
eat more precise okay so I'm going to so
given this given this intuition I'm
going to define a new hash function
family which is trying to form these
collisions of G's so the inputs the
domain for the sash function family is
functions from G and the output is like
the output of the original H and the way
that this new uh function family works
is that given an input of a description
of the time of a function of G
you run your attack your adversary for
our candidate crh F and that this
Collision X1 X2 and you output h of X1
which is supposed to be the same as h of
X2
and I want to prove that this guy is a
series
so let's do this
so suppose that it is not
what does it mean is that you can attack
this new hash function family its key is
just H right so now it means the given
age you can find the condition for this
previous function time so you can find G
which is different from G Prime so that
their evaluation is the same meaning
that the H of X1 that you get here the
same stage of X1 Prime to get here
so let's sort of uh see what this what
this tells us well when we run a and
equal G we get X1 and X2 and then and G
Prime we've got X One Prime and X2 Prime
and we know because a works that you
know exponent actually from a condition
under both H and G
we know that X1 Prime and X2 Prime form
a Collision under both H and G and we
know because uh of this that h of X1 is
equal to H of X on Prime
so putting this out together you know we
have a four-way Collision we have H of
X1 is equal to H of X2 equal to H of X1
Prime equal to H of x two prime
and then even to use that need to use
any property of G
so that's exactly right so our concern
is you know
if that's the Justified concern is what
if it's the same Collision
so it's uh it's a multi set of size four
but is it actually a substance
so that's what's worrying me and I want
to ensure that it's not the case and
that's where I'm going to use properties
of G okay so what do we know so far so
we know that g is different from G Prime
but we have the G of X1 is equal to G of
X2 and G Prime of X1 Prime is equal to G
Prime of X of uh X2 Prime
wouldn't it be great if we could
guarantee that for any distinct pair X1
and X2 there's only one g on which they
can Collide that's such a situation
um as above could not occur there's only
one such pair that can exist so I want
to set up G to have that property
okay with so we understood this and this
you know rang the bell from uh
elementary school or something
but you know if you look at two distinct
pairs of lines they can intersect them
with most one point okay so we would
like to have a construction in which the
x1s played the role of lines
and G
of X1 corresponds to the evaluation of
the line at some point and then two
lines
X1 and X2 can intersect and at most 1G
okay so more specifically
what do we do
it'll be a three-way Collision yes yes
just guarantee that these two pairs are
different exactly
so we're going to fix the finite field
of size 2 to the N over 2.
each function uh G is going to be
specified by a field element it's like
where we looked at on the line
and each point x we're going to
interpret as a line so you can think of
it you know interpret it in your
favorite way over this field as two
field elements Say by coefficients
okay
and then you know fun fact if you like
any two distinct X1 and x and x Prime
there's a degree a one polynomials they
can be the same with most one point
they're different
to be is this the most 1G on which they
agree
questions
okay so we have found as time was saying
we found a three-way Collision why
would we know you know no this copy from
the previous slide all of this we know
but now I'm claiming that it cannot be
the case like what if that was concerned
about that these religions are the same
why if they were the same then uh you
know we have uh both G and G Prime which
uh you know
uh these two lines intersect on two
points both on G and G Prime
okay
so we found the three-let relation for H
but H is uh you know three equation
resistance we have a contradiction
okay questions
so let's talk about the shrinkage yes
and I'm probably going to talk about is
expand this trick you start with a fire
I'm going to come over and then you're
using like not a blind forever
and
this one
so you know G is mapping n is to n over
two bits so it's about this so if you
look if you think if you call the
original the candidate construction was
like appending these n over two bits so
your output n minus l so the original
thing plus n over two so it's still
going to be shrinking as long as you're
losing at least n over two so that's
okay
the second guy its input was you know
um a description of a function of from
uh sorry a description of a function
from G to specify by field element so
there are two to the N over two such
guys meaning that the size of the input
for this candidate thing was n over 2.
and it was still outputting the N minus
L things of the original graph
so as long as L is still same again L
still needs to be bigger than n over 2
then you're still shrinking
okay so as long as the original thing
was shooting by more than n over two we
are happy
yeah okay
okay so question I'm going to uh
question of you know can you do better
you know we're very naive we went to
elementary school maybe if you go to
High School uh you can do better by
choosing G better I yes you asked if you
can rule out uh other you know
approaches I remember I mean I
reinterpreting
so the answer turns out to be Nokia and
um you can show this about Singleton
down they won't show it okay so this is
a choice of G is essentially optimal
here right so if you follow this
blueprint
okay
questions about uh 3M series the
construction yeah
analysis or the you know
because
so we really we're trying to form
different religions in age
okay so uh first of all if we think of
like non-uniform adversaries they don't
need to worry about it did we uh I mean
in the election paper just uh the non
uniform I randomized some expected
should not be a big deal but uh
whatever will happen from final
collision and stuff
let me just also output it that will be
fine
okay
so I want to talk about uh
let's talk about how do we how do you to
go from Forum CH to crh
so actually I'll show you how to go from
form crh to three times the origin and
we can apply the previous thing so as a
predicted same basic idea we uh
try to be the Collision finder now that
finds distinct G Prime and g double
Prime
uh but instead of looking that it is a
line we look at the the Bluetooth curve
as predicted so actually let me skip
this and go directly to what I wanted to
say about tlm series whether it's a
little bit more interesting so from trm
to CR how do I improve the T Factor
so here I'm going to choose a smarter
finite field by by some parameter K so
that I look at the input and I see K
field elements instead of the line
corresponding to field elements and I'm
going to interpret them as a degree K
minus one polynomial
and as before I Define the function to
be you know h of X my original mcrh
tlmcrh and I output this value of I'm
thinking of X as I'm interpreting X as a
polynomial a degree K polynomial and
evaluating it at the point G
okay as before
so now I asked as before you know so
let's say I'm trying to to say that
either the candidate construction here
is a T1 mcrh or an argument one is a T2
and direction I can try to balance the
parameters so this guy is a good T1 mcrh
super happy so the interesting case in
which it's not they can find here
collisions right so given h
and G I can find T1 size collisions
so now I can try to run you know I build
again exactly as before this new mcra
e exactly before I run a
so I get the input G I run a I get this
T1 size collision and I output its value
and now you know
if I suppose that this this other
construction is not the t2 I'm crh I can
find T2 size collisions so I can build
up this big table right for each one of
these T2 size Collision I have like a G1
up to G T2 and for each one I found that
T1 size Collision so I have this big
nice table full of uh of x's now each X
is a polynomial
so I have this Matrix T1 by T2 are full
of polynomials and the property that I
know is that if you look at the I throw
each row has a uh is exactly T1 distinct
polynomials that all agree on the value
GI
for that row
right so table full of polynomials
really happy and the entire question
that I want to ask for algebraic
question is what is the minimum number
so in adverse I might try to you know
put in here the least amount of
polynomials so that I don't find a big
Collision so how many polynomials can I
pack in here
so that I still have this property
the question makes sense we're talking
about Union right
there uh yeah yeah that's true so we
Analyze This via research on a listing
coding so the point is you know if you
further set up this table and you look
at them you think of you know a function
which gets all of these polynomials
agree on G1 and some value to give a
function that has this value here and
this value here and so on you get some
description of a of a function
yes you know the number of different
polynomials here is very small then
overall it means that there are a lot of
polynomials that agree with this
function realistically tell us that this
cannot be the case
so this is why you know we have some not
so nice formula
um based basically on this side
it's related to your approach if there
was a different approach using designs
for example
so first of all you can replace you can
put any code that you want here and we
can use this mystical beam to analyze
this
um you don't get much better mode we got
from
[Music]
um
what did I want to say uh but oh maybe
just emphasize are we cares about
combinatories because we don't need
efficient algorithms how many numbers
can you plug in you it's the one of the
adversary to find themselves great
questions
okay
so so far I was talking about you know
perfect adversary I want to say uh in
the time that I have left I wanted to
talk about how we deal with you know
imperfect adversaries and there are
various ways in which an adversary may
be imperfect
so problem number one is that the
adversary never certain attention you
may only succeed on an infinite number
of input lengths so I already told you
how I started that I basically assumed
it away so our resulting crh is only
going to be infinitely offensive care
get around it it would be great if you
don't know how so that's one thing
more interesting you know the adversary
that we assumed for our candidate crh it
gets an input H and G and sometimes it
works it finds conditions sometimes it
doesn't work
so let's first consider the case that it
only works for a small fraction of the
H's
so the way we handle this is by sort of
in our construction of the the other the
eventual fa crh we boost up these H's in
which the adversary likes to succeed
right so we we sample an H we checked
does the adversary like to work on this
H if it does great if no we do a sort of
rejection sampling
the problem is that this sort of uh
you know what's the word
um
sort of messing around with the
probability space Also messes around the
success probability of the end adversary
that we have like mapping the end
adversaries that we have for fa to an
attack on the original age but we bound
this effect so it's an effect by a
multiplicative factor which we can bound
um so that's that the last thing is
maybe the most uh two so I'll show you
so suppose that this fa that we
constructed remember its input was a
description of function G and we mapped
we
outputted this Collision suppose that
only works for a small fraction of the
G's
what will we get that this fa basically
on the G is for which the adversary
doesn't work we kind of get nothing so
let's say we have to bottom so this kind
of gives rise to the notion of the
partial domain crh to kind of think of
now if uh if I lost you we can sort of
come back so the situation think of a
situation in which we have a hash
function might bring n Bits to say n
minus uh at least Omega log n Bits And
this hash function is such that you know
on some noticeable fraction of the
domain it doesn't output bottom
so for a large fractional domain now at
the bottom but for a noticeable fraction
it does not and I'm asking you can you
find the Collision of course not the
bottom and respect noticeable error
so this is we have this a partial domain
crh
and what we show is that if you have a
partial domain crh you can get a
full-fledged here
because in general amplify this way
um in what sense but if you have a
sewage which is only only Collision
system is very any small this is not
this is not in the if you're talking
about the the range I agree but here to
The Domain you have you know the
function is only defined on Smart parts
of the domain
and now I want to build something else
that's defined and only zero once again
I see in terms of the domain yeah are
you translating
yes
it's important that their circuits is
super long replay uh yeah because
otherwise you'd have like the trivial
thing right
in which the collisions do not exist in
this noticeable part
it just needs to be meaningful
questions but if you like
you're asking how sharp it is it is that
uh I'm not sure like after a bit I do
not check so I liked this kind of
question
yes and so before that if your uh
construction is not uniform as it is
does it have to be infinitely often
yes
which does not work I don't know
the construction oh is certainly there's
an
instructions
Okay so
uh I'm going to do translations I think
this is what you meant so we'll just uh
technique that you know
um right by uh I think the first
implications
or a normal hierarchy but it's been used
in many Works in cryptography uh mostly
by money and by near uh maybe that
covers everything
okay so how do you go from pressure
domain crh to fur domain crh by the way
I think it's a
it's uh when you see it for the first
time it's shocking um then we get used
to it and it's still shocking but uh we
appreciate it so here's the idea so I
take my partial domain uh crh this is H
and we have to consider Shifting the
input space okay so Z1 up to Z K are
possible different shifts of the input
space and the way that I Define my new
hash function H Prime is that I'm going
to consider the first shift
but as far as in my area that does work
and I output the hash value of that
point
so the entire family is like this it's
not the hash key is described by the
original hash key as well as these
shifts Z1 up to ZK but the original
series which is only partial domain yes
function to function in the family or
the fixedness
these shifts are random
and there are parts of the description
of the hash
em
yes translate this is what you mean by
translation yeah so they translate it
and go to the first translation that you
know works and then also output which
one works yeah here I'm losing logins
uh question Marshall question
and know this so and I have put the
first one
so first a claim we ended with high
probability over disease so for every
look at some particular X let's say with
very high probability over the disease
this like I would find an eye for which
this is defined why because you know you
repeat enough times it will work this is
true for any individual economic
communion bound to be true for all of
x's
okay so this is where the miracle
happens
um so that's a proof of that and notice
that if you're able to find the
Collision for this hash function family
you can directly translate it into a
collision for the original age right you
know peeling away the shift
questions
so uh let me sort of End by pointing out
some uh open questions including things
that were raised here today uh so one
big thing you know get rid of all these
annoying qualifiers and in particular
one thing that would be very nice is to
try to use a universal construction I
say you know two things that seem to me
programmatically Universal construction
but you can just like
change change the the game so first of
all I think for a universal construction
you want to think about uniform security
because you want to do some sort of uh
conversation kind of thing go over
everything so for non-uniform I think I
don't see how to do it for uniform
there's more potential
the other thing to me that seems
important is don't think about you know
putting number time adversaries but
think of like fixed time so enter the
login time adversary and then
potentially you can do something and not
not entirely sure but in that you know
something there's potential to do to do
something
um so that's that the other thing I
already pointed out for five amps here
which I don't know how to do anything
if one of you guys manages to do it
fantastic then I would ask about six and
you know any other constant once you're
done with that we'll start going to
Superman so there's plenty plenty of
papers to write and uh stuff to do here
another question you know uh mcrh you
know Black Box separated from uh crh so
um at some point there was a claim about
this but there was a box apparently it's
open
um
three from twos is open
another separation for a distribution
from what from what to what
for multi-pleasure resistance to
distribution or even distribution or
just uh
um I don't think so
in your apartment
separation would be great
um last thing I think it's you know it's
somewhat weird to use the adversary
constructively but you know we got
something out of it uh hopefully more
can be gotten out of it particularly
very you know complexity people in the
crowd maybe it's Randomness maybe in
other fields it's to be useful uh or
whether you've seen a further use of it
in the context of uh by uh Abhishek
who's cheers
um they use a sort of a similar status
technique maybe this can be useful
um you know the biggest question I think
in this area is you know trying to build
produce resistant hash functions from
when we function the wrong way
permutations seems incredibly hard right
we have Simon's result which shows that
uh an oracle separation
but you know I think maybe I didn't say
our technique is not black box right
after that we're using the adversary the
adversary does crazy thing with the
construction it's not that box maybe you
can use this type of idea to get you
know get around Simon so uh at science
so we're not the sandwich but at the big
university I was uh I was proposing this
but then we start pointed out as virus
technique is not Black Box it does
relative words so it's with my bypass
Oracle separations
so for people doing Black Box operations
which are not Oracle separations just be
aware that sometimes uh Black Box
operations are not enough
okay so I think
[Applause]
this is
so much
again
one step
foreign
questions
please control the classical part
something really classical and then even
before she was invented